لدينا بعض أسئلة المشاهدين لك يا
سانجاي والسؤال الأول
هو بصراحة أعتقد أن أحد الأسئلة الأكثر شيوعًا
الآن وهو كثيرًا
في الخطاب العام ،
هذا السؤال هو هل ما زلنا بحاجة إلى
ارتداء أقنعة
خارج سانجاي خاصة إذا تم تطعيمك
لماذا ويجب أن يظل الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم
يرتدون أقنعة في الخارج ،
لذا دعني أحاول الإجابة
بهذه الطريقة أعتقد أن
الغالبية العظمى من انتقال الفيروس
المعذرة
لي لا يحدث في الخارج في الواقع قمنا
بتجميع بعض الأرقام
التي تحدثنا عنها  أه حقيقة أنه
بشكل عام ، إذا نظرت إلى
حالات جديدة لأشخاص أصيبوا بالعدوى ، فإن
أقل من 10 في
المائة يحدث في الهواء الطلق ، وقد تتذكر جون أن
هذه إحصائية
شاركناها قبل أن
ننظر في الواقع إلى
انتقال الفيروس ونجد أنه
قريب  إلى 19 مرة أقل احتمالية للحدوث في
الهواء الطلق مقابل الداخل ، فما هي
العوامل التي تجعل ذلك مختلفًا ،
أود أن أقول في معظم الأحيان أنك لست بحاجة
إلى ارتداء قناع في الهواء الطلق  هناك
دول في جميع أنحاء العالم مثل إسرائيل
تقول أنك لم تعد بحاجة إلى القيام
بذلك وأعتقد أنه عليك فقط استخدام الفطرة السليمة
هنا ، أعني أن الفيروس
معدي ولا يحب أن يكون في الهواء الطلق
ولا يحب أن يكون في ضوء الشمس
ولكن إذا كنت متجمعًا بشكل وثيق
معًا إذا كان هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
في منطقة واحدة ، إذا كنت ستبقى
هناك لفترات طويلة
، وهناك تحذير آخر مهم للغاية وهو
ما هو نوع انتقال الفيروس
في منطقتك
إذا كان هناك  الكثير من انتشار الفيروسات في
منطقتك ، الكثير من الاختبارات الإيجابية ، الكثير
من
الإيجابية العالية ، قد تفكر
في أنه إذا كنت ستواجه هذا النوع
من المواقف ،
فإن السؤال الحقيقي الذي تحاول
الإجابة عنه وهناك الكثير من العوامل التي
ادخل إلى هذا ،
ما هو احتمال أن
أستنشق هواء شخص آخر
وهذا أساسًا هو عدد الأشخاص
من نوع الإعداد
الواضح في الداخل مقابل الهواء الطلق
وما هو
الانتشار الفيروسي العام في مجتمعك ،
وأنا أعلم أنه كان عارضًا
سؤال ولكن
ربما قد تراجعت عن ذلك أو
أسأل عما إذا كنا نسأل عن عارض
أدريانا كيلر من واشنطن دي سي ،
وأنت تعلم أيضًا أن هذا
سؤال لديه الكثير من الناس سؤال مشاهد آخر
وأعتقد أنه سؤال ربما
لم نكن نستمتع بالترفيه منذ أشهر
ولكن الآن يتم تطعيم الناس ، لذا ما
مدى أمان الجلوس داخل
مطعم ،
نعم هذا سؤال كبير كما
أعتقد أنه أحد الأسئلة الأكثر شيوعًا التي
تلقيتها من
عائلتي و  الأصدقاء الذين تعرفهم
شيئًا عن
تناول الطعام في الأماكن المغلقة لا يزال إذا كان حقًا في الداخل هو
أن التهوية هناك هي
السؤال الكبير الذي أعود إلى ما كنت
أتحدث عنه للتو حول
مدى احتمالية أن تتنفس
هواء شخص آخر
الآن إذا تم تطعيم الجميع  كما
تعلم ، أعتقد أنك تعلم أنك في وضع
مختلف تمامًا من
غير
المحتمل أن يمرض الناس وليس من
المحتمل أن ينشروا الفيروس ،
لكنني أعتقد أنك تعرف متى
ستذهب لتناول الطعام في الداخل إذا  ذ  أنت في
منطقة من البلد حيث لا يزال
هناك الكثير من انتشار الفيروسات ، من
الواضح أنك تصادف
الكثير من المنازل المختلفة ومن
الواضح أنه يتعين عليك إزالة قناعك
لتناول الطعام أو الشراب ، وهذا هو مصدر القلق الكبير على ما
أعتقد
في معظم الأماكن  في البلد ، لا يزال من
المؤكد أن تناول الطعام في الأماكن المغلقة بكامل طاقته ،
لا يمكنني تخيل أنه
سيُنصح بذلك ، أعني
أنه لا يزال هناك مخاطرة كبيرة لأنه لا
تزال هناك فرصة كبيرة للغاية
لأنك ستعرض بالفعل
للفيروس على ما
أعتقد  قدرة محدودة والنظر
إلى ما يفعله الفيروس في مجتمعك